I'm a little hungry
Marie is Eiki I'm fine but what should I do?
I don't know what I was doing here
There are so many people around my age The
building is beautiful like a castle It's really fun
It's
fun
Kasumi Toshiro with me  In the same class
[music]
They're stupid and noisy, so they ask me all kinds of troublesome things, but
it's actually fun
and I thought it would be nice to continue
[music]
Kitakami at my refuge Now,
there for a year  Because of the time-changed
senpai, I'm falling in love with you.
The four of us were together That's
it now
[music]
Then I can be the 5th one I'll be the
number one
[music]
Yua Kisaki It's
definitely fun, I promise
[music]